welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about all your
marvel superheroes wardrobes and their
wardrobe malfunctions
more importantly giving me a good rub
we're going there today i'm eric boss
here with philip molina how you doing
man
i'm doing great i'm wearing shorts and
no one will ever know oh good i'm just
glad you're wearing something down there
because i have been burned before in
past uh remote shoots and that rogue
theory episode oh god oh
never forget my eyes were bulging
anyway uh you want to know what the big
question is yeah let's do it speaking of
advertised questions
jason on twitter at jaytreesapp
uh wants to know how do hero suits
interact with their normal clothes and
i'm going to kind of rephrase this
because interacting with clothes it
doesn't apply to all the heroes and some
of them don't wear clothes and some of
them do
so instead i think what he's getting at
is the impracticalities
of how the suit meets clothes or being
alive
or needing to survive a fight or any of
these things so i want to ask you
this is a tweak on jason's question
which major superheroes have just like
the worst most impractical suits
and like specifically like this is just
phillip here not jason jason i'm not
throwing you in here but like how do
they pee
do they pee and like okay some can pee
but like can they poop
this is very important to me in for a
future uh uh
occupation i'm considering important to
only you
but it's it's one that we will answer
i'm glad i got this question because we
just broke down spider-man homecoming in
our ongoing infinity saga rewatch series
and
to me one of the standout moments from
that movie is peter parker's awkwardness
with this suit
like he has to strip off his clothes in
public
and then like put it on but he's like
excited it was the first time in the mcu
or at least with spider-man where it was
really thought out what it means for
this guy to have to
stretch this thing on his body every
time
he goes out into the world it's like
minutes precious minutes
it takes so much time how many deaths
are getting on his hands
as a result of this
so you know we used to do a segment a
bunch of new rockstars breakdowns called
the new rockstars was it the fashion
roundup
oh god the red carpet recap i don't
remember what we called it i remember
banning it but let's do one of these no
i banned it
the rules have changed but the players
are the same all right let's let's start
with spider-man because that's what we
were just talking about right okay so
his suit type he has this form-fitting
cloth that's most likely spandex
or something similar well the suit that
he gets from tony stark
in uh civil war and the one that he uses
in homecoming and beyond
it has some inner wiring some tech it
has like a chip and boards in it
it can you know light up it has thermals
in it
and then he upgraded to the iron spider
and infinity war in game
it's a pretty cool suit we don't want to
hate on it too much on the iron spider
suit
all the spider-man suits i mean the iron
spider suit is like on a whole other
level this is like
like you're going from especially the
fursuit his hoodie
basically would like goggles but no
matter what spider-man suit you're
dealing with
uh usually it's not stealthy unless it's
the stealth version of the suit and far
from home
the night monkey night monkey yeah yeah
it's uh it's all one piece so it's
sweaty he usually has to wear it
underneath everything
but the thing is in homecoming he does
take off his clothes but it shrink wraps
around man as a vacuum
sealant so he doesn't have to wear
nothing underneath it
but i think he wants to take off his
clothes so that he doesn't have that
lumpy silhouette yeah i think he wants
it to be clinging to the skin
[Music]
i think peter parker it's like just
telling that he's like a kid and he's
like he like wants to look cool and he
wants flash thompson to say like cool
things about him
but if he had like lumps from like you
know when you have your cell phone in
your pocket in a picture or
in your keys in the other pocket you're
like i look like i have a ton of grapes
in my pants
or like if you've ever worn your hanger
in your shirt by accident he doesn't
want to look like that
i had a late start that day and i had to
rush to the interview
and i got it here i have it new rock
stars yeah oh hanger boy the nickname is
gone
okay so some examples of this right he
does lose his backpack
in that scene at spider-man homecoming
so he has to like go home to change
and that ends up being what outs him to
ned and has an awkward moment
with aunt may when she thinks like oh my
son is just like
shirtless and his boxers hanging out
with his best friend
he doesn't have super speed so that
actually is a huge default of if you
have to change into this outfit
if you don't have something to change
back into you're stuck
presenting yourself as spider-man right
and uh part of the reason
why he takes off his clothes is because
like that's part of his identity and
maybe he doesn't want to wear like his
school clothes underneath it because he
doesn't want to like out himself where
people are like taking pictures like
wait he was wearing this weird collared
shirt it was clearly like a collared
shirt and a belt
and pants that he was wearing underneath
that like i could tell by his by the cut
of his jeans who that spider-man is
that's like what is that a old racist
uh mom who doesn't want you hanging out
with that boy i can tell by the cut of
his jeans
he's a party boy oh not everything in
the past is well actually you know what
everything old is racist yeah yeah the
moon landing was racist as hell
it's one small step for man one
giant leap for white people you're
saying
no black guys on the moon also something
we should point out something that sucks
about the homecoming era suit is it has
i would say too many features you should
not give a 16 year old kid an
instant kill feature even if it is
blocked by the training wheels protocol
it's still dangerous to have that
somewhere in the suit yeah as an option
and and let him know it's like hey look
peter this is a loaded gun
it you know there's a training wheel on
it but i'm leaving it right here
now another drawback for even redesigns
like you got to think the far from home
stealth suit oh it's it's an improvement
but it is still
too tight in the crotch you're dealing
with a kid who is very very concerned
about this thing
so if it's mushed up in the crotch
though and is putting pressure on the
crotch and his bladder's full
eric here we go eric he can't pee no
phillip he can't pee in the suit he
would have to take it off
but here's the here's the thing if he's
wearing the iron spider suit we're
talking about a tony stark design style
armor that's a fast quick change
he probably could take that off also
this is post the iron man 2 suit
in iron man 2 that version of the armor
had a filtration
unit in it right so that you could pee
in it just like that so presumably peter
parker's suit that was designed
for suborbital altitude yeah you could
probably be
a thing fine if it's the iron spider
suit i agree with you it's powered by
pee
but if it's not the iron spider suit
then he's just making a mess of himself
he's just making a big old mess
who's next okay next up we just
mentioned him iron man okay so
he has armor and depending on what era
it is it's a gold titanium alloy but
there have been 85 versions over the
years
culminating in the nanobot weave of the
mark 50 that was even further upgraded
into the mark 85 and avengers end game
i i almost have my own big question for
you to do in a future episode he's done
85 versions of the suit
and that doesn't mean just 85 suits he
could have built hundreds of suits right
just 85 actual upgrades so then i
i gotta wonder and we can talk about it
in a future episode how long does it
take tony stark to make an iron man suit
that he can just like crank him out like
that it's like hours
[Music]
yeah it's confusing because even in the
movies he kind of upgrades to a new
version of the suit within the span of a
movie
but uh if you think about it he probably
had that in the works for years and now
he's finally like okay
time to bring out this one because the
mark 43 got smashed so we'll bring out
the 44.
yeah it's uh it's insane how much this
guy tinkers so it's an awesome suit we
love iron man's armor we've made plenty
of videos about it but it sucks
it does suck why it is too heavy
it's clunky it's not flexible it's armor
it's freaking armor it's a suit of armor
there's a reason why
uh knights in the medieval times stopped
wearing full armored suits because you
can't be that flexible in it
and there's no shock so if you get
knocked off your horse be falling
into metal if you bang your head against
it it's gonna be worse than falling onto
soft grass
wait but he doesn't have shock
absorption we've talked about this a
number of times
it goes back and forth if he has shock
absorption i mean
maybe the reason rhodey got hurt so bad
is because his suit turned off
but like why would that matter is there
some kind of like um
arc reactor energy that allows for the
shocks to work versus not
i mean you you could imagine like it
kind of tries to use like repulsors to
slow down his descent
repulsors are one thing but like tony
stark hits sides of buildings
he he runs into stuff all the time
without having repulsors to use newton's
third law
to put an equal and opposite reaction to
that hit he doesn't know when
he's gonna run into something so he's
shattered constantly he is broken
he is broken it doesn't make any sense i
hurt myself
today all of his organs turn into flesh
anymore also a big design flaw
arguably is the fact that the arc
reactor is exposed and that everyone
knows that that's what you go for
it's like the uh ocarina of time
villains you just as soon as you know
what the blinking thing is that's what
you aim for
yeah and then you take down the boss
like just go for the arc reactor i was
thinking of the star
fox uh villain where he's got like the
buttons on his hands and it's like
well don't put the button on your hand
now i know what to do that's what it is
you don't want your enemy to know what
to aim for when they're trying to take
you down
so some examples of when we've seen this
suit suck
you're like pissed at this the various
different versions have sucked in
different ways and then tony stark
improves on it
it's fine but just some examples of how
it interacts with your clothes
usually what's interesting you can wear
your normal clothes underneath all
versions of the armor even back to the
mark one armor he's wearing clothes he
kind of wraps himself up a little bit
but he's wearing like
clothes but his clothes are already like
a billionaire's form-fitting bespoke
suits like perfectly sized if he was
wearing like george's gore-tex
jacket he'd have to take that off
[Music]
but the scene in iron man 3 is the crazy
one where both he and rody are jumping
in and out of all different kinds of
armor
it's in miami they're wearing one layer
that's still a layer that seems like it
could snag on something yeah
right so that's pretty impressive that
you can jump in and out
while wearing your street clothes it's
pretty effective and through the years
those quick changes get
more and more efficient so it starts
with like it takes forever to put the
suit on
and then iron man 2 he's got the
suitcase avengers he can jump out and
the thing deploys and it catches in
midair which is crazy
iron man 3 he's got the mark 42 which is
symbols and pieces around him
and then eventually nanotech nanotech
where just comes out of his uh like
chess piece but even then
that's a lot of weight one has to carry
in your chest
for the full armor to go around your
body is it like the bleeding edge though
maybe it's like spread through his blood
yeah you're talking about like fantasy
versus science well that's like
i bet then tony stark probably weighs
like 290 pounds or something oh yeah he
must like and
but does the nanobots help his muscles
carry this when they're not at use
you know maybe yeah it's kind of crazy
and in the movies it's not bleeding edge
it's not in his blood it's all
in this external piece anyway so like is
that helping him
carry itself like are there tiny little
repulsors that are like
moving it to counteract the weight of
gravity that he would have to carry
doesn't totally make sense because it's
a movie
but it's okay we still love it here's
the answer he would have super strength
if that was the case just all the time
as a normal dude so yeah other ways it
sucks and end game it doesn't protect
him from snap radiation huge design flaw
he dies
and then in civil war bucky and cap they
aim for that arc reactor and that's
really all they have to do to put him
down when he's the freaking iron man he
should be able to take them both down
pretty easily especially once he knocks
the shield out of their hands i mean
literally just put like a little like
you know
hood like a little toyota emblem thing
right in front of it
and that like that's probably all he
needs to do so overall iron man's armor
pretty cool just sucks in a couple key
ways but we can we can move on before
philip remembers to ask his questions
wait no hold on
i was well the thing is you already
answered the question he has the
filtration system
yes but he filtered poo poo that much is
not clear we don't know if it's number
two
you gotta imagine like what is the piece
that allows him to do it is his um
catheter in there is there like an
astronaut style funnel
you think you know how they all come
flying all the pieces come flying and
like attach you think one of them is a
catheter that just flies
up into them i think it's more likely to
be the astronaut style
funnel that goes around it you know and
then you can just
uh let it go but it's connected it's
like a
wet condom most of those dry sand paper
condoms do not use those kids they're
fun but
don't did i ever tell you that my my
brother woke up once in the hospital
uh he was like feeling really sick and
then and then he just passed out and he
didn't know why and he woke up
and the only thing he knew was he was
all alone and there was a cord
coming out of his wiener and he started
to like tug on it and it turned out that
he
it wasn't just because he had a catheter
it was like
they had eventually figured out that he
had this kidney stone he wasn't able to
pass
it was just crazy but he was just like
it was so crazy man and then i wasn't
allowed to get a boner for weeks
my brother is crazy wasn't allowed to he
wasn't he said he had to ice it every
morning
to prevent morning wood uh okay
what do you mean okay you don't have a
bigger response to this weird
unnecessary anecdote about my brother's
wiener
i listened to that man your your sister
married
story last time
[Laughter]
i'll wait oh wait
i'll be there dumbledore move on yeah he
doesn't i don't think he's got one for
poop
poop is just something that they don't
want to address all right moving on
quickly to
steve rogers captain america so he has a
suit it's not really necessary for his
uh super powers really all he needs is a
shield and he's cool as we saw in
captain america winter soldier once he
loses his suit uh but just to talk about
his suit it's a tactical padded like
special op
style suit depending on what era he's in
it usually has straps
and a belt and he has a helmet so it's
cool but it also kind of sucks
because it has limited protection not
like he needs it but
he could use some it's not bulletproof
he gets shot
he gets hit with tony stark's blasts
that that hurts him
it's not really clear how much it hurts
him it's also pretty easy to track
because it is red and white
and blue hell yeah america he has a
stealth version in winter soldier and
once he turns into the nomad version in
infinity war well infinity war his
stealth version is he weird like he like
peeled off the star and he like dirt he
peeled out the star
and at civil war he ripped off the
avengers insignia which happened
off-screen but it was cool when
we saw that people are like i think
that's captain america but like
in a crappy suit and he's got a beard is
he okay do we need to check in
also you can imagine that helmet might
block his peripheral vision like he has
great senses anyway and
he has a magnetic shield that will come
back to him as of age of ultron also
people pointed out that his uh suit
design and the first cap had both
suspenders and
a belt which is redundant but that was a
style back in the 40s so well but
also if he's fighting you know scissor
man he like cuts both suspenders his
pants don't fall
so um sometimes it's cool but i would
say overall cap's
caps cooler when he doesn't have a suit
on so uh that's my take i think a
suitcase
most people are not disagreeing with you
that he does better
out of clothes and also i mean i don't
even need to ask so dude wears pants of
course he can pee and he can poop he's a
very practical man
yeah yeah you just take off yeah zip
down i'm sure it's fine why
why would uh shield in the 40s design a
suit that you you couldn't
in the 40s that's all people did that's
how you pass the time yeah okay
all right let's move on to uh black
panther t'challa so very interesting
suit
it's a vibranium weave it assembles from
a necklace over
whatever you're wearing so if you're if
you're wearing it under your clothes
it'll uh
it'll tear off your clothes i guess if
you're wearing it over your clothes
it'll assemble over your clothes
it's very sleek it's one of the cooler
pieces of design tech in the mcu
uh it's similar to the mark 50 nanotech
but it's necklace based
so it's a sleek but it's also kind of
crappy because it's a necklace someone
can take it off you you can lose it
people lose necklaces and jewelry all
the time it looks like really sharp like
they pull on really hard they just cut
his head off
or if it's just like if you go on um one
of those carnival rides
it might just like loosen in a weird way
and it starts to poke your chest the
gravitron
like the gravitron or one of those ones
with the video cameras on it
and people pass out when they get
slingshotted in the air oh
yikes i don't know i've never been on
one of those faces of death
whoa that is not what i was referencing
so you keep bringing that up in
conversation
so some examples of why this isn't as
cool as it could be
in a black panther apparently t'chaka in
the past said that he was too fat for
the suit meaning that you have to be in
great shape to wear it
which that's not fair i want you know to
be able to jump into a tony stark style
iron man suit no matter what shape i'm
in
but because the it's designed to be worn
by the black panther it's someone who's
in peak physical condition
my car has a trunk that has a button and
sometimes i overfill the trunk and you
see the trunk go like
come on and it jams all my stuff then
you want that with a suit yeah yeah i
want to be able to do that
but maybe that's the idea is like if
you're nothing without the suit you
shouldn't wear it if you're not an
instagram model
you shouldn't have the suit but also
like i bet they have sped up metabolism
right so like
how much does it take to become a
chubster in that scenario
they have a lot of yummy looking street
food that i'm sure you keep
bringing that up that one's yours that
you keep bringing i want to try
the street food in wakanda it looks so
freaking good
now the suit also the tech has some
weaknesses right uh it's vulnerable to
that magnetized vibranium
trains that pass that remember that
amazing third act of black panther with
the shitty effects
but like that's how they defeated them
was remembering that the trains have
magnets on them
it was a great movie third act needed
some work maybe
magnus though how do they work nobody
knows
one of the greatest mysteries also we
found out in a black panther prelude
comic this was actually years before
civil war when he was the black panther
but it wasn't the king of wakanda yet
they are vulnerable to vibranium bullets
which you know makes sense as a
vibranium weave if it's strong enough a
sharp enough bullet
a fired powerfully enough it should be
able to break through
but you're gonna think like if they're
like controlling all of wakanda's access
and design weaponry for vibranium they
should be able to build something that
can withstand the strongest
weapon version of that right yeah quick
question uh to let me know the answer to
in the comments uh
if you if you know this kind of stuff
what would happen if you had diamond
bullets
and also like diamond bullets shooting
at a very large diamond would it like
even chip at it or would it blast right
through it would it shatter the whole
thing
and where can i find these diamond
bullets oh god do not tell philip the
answer this question
there's a diamond person he wants to
kill
or what if he had to use a bathroom in
the suit actually yes
you could be in the suit uh pretty
easily just
because it's it's like the nanotech it's
even faster i think it could quickly
retract off you
and then you do your business and then
it uh reassembles you know
if you think about it the nanotech like
it doesn't like wrap his dong and
vibranium right and like in like falls
and stuff
it like creates like just like a general
lump over the whole area
and then so it probably just like opens
up scares the hell out of somebody
hey i think that's black panther don't
look over here kids
and then it scoops itself back up puts
himself away and then it seals itself oh
black panther's back on that school
playground kids cover your eyes
what are those gross all right let's
shift over
to the dc universe because we haven't
forgot about you guys we love dc just as
much as marvel even more than marvel if
we're talking about comics are you sure
about that anyway
okay starting with batman he's all about
his suit right because he's not super
powered so it's all
in his suit and in his anger so he has
depending on what version of the comics
the movies you're looking at typically
we're talking about a triple weave
kevlar bodysuit
with varying uh bells and whistles and
different features
but most commonly known about it the
suit overall itself
is usually not bulletproof usually just
the chest emblem
is bulletproof that's why it's so flashy
and yellow it's like a trick
it's a theatrical trick by bruce wayne
to try to lure shooters to aim for his
chest which we've said before draws the
fire
maybe put that like on your foot instead
of
close to your face or vital organs
yeah so it's not totally practical also
let's just be honest
capes are pretty much never practical
the incredibles edumode was 100 right
right when she
said your baby has multiple times
you shouldn't think of another edna mode
quote multiple sclerosis
uh but anything i know you're gonna say
oh well the cape helps them glide
or the cape can be fire resistant
whatever feature it has
you could just apply that to the rest of
the suit he could just have uh yeah like
nightwing you don't need a cape a cape
is just for theatrical purposes it's
never practical a cape is stupid knock
it
i'll give you one idea but he doesn't
use it this way but he could
maybe that's his like ninja styles that
he hides in the shadows by completely
wrapping himself in the cape
and a futuristic version like a batman
beyond version well he already can turn
invisible you're right the suit itself
turns invisible on that one
yeah camo you know there's there's all
kinds of more practical things that are
real-life military has figured out
but uh just to give some examples
various versions have had pieces of him
be bulletproof so like
the dark knight movies hit parts of his
armor are bulletproof
but like he wants to be more flexible so
like there are more gaps in his armor
that are installed in the dark knight
versions that leaves them vulnerable to
knives from the joker and from talia
algol
also though if we're recounting the fact
that in these movies he often can't turn
his head
that's also a problem like the more
armored you make something the less
flexibility you have so the more armored
versions of it that are more about the
silhouette
the less practical and fluid they are
that's why like in a lot of these movies
everyone kind of looks the same in their
chunky armor because they're all
applying like real world like
a special ops and and what armor would
actually look like if you want to fight
with it
and none of it's flashy or cool looking
it's just kind of serves a function and
that's it yeah and what's it like when
he pees
okay so uh depending on the suit like if
it's in pieces
you would think bruce wayne would put
that in there because you know he's like
he stakes out stuff all the time the
guy's
out all night he's gonna have to pee at
some point he's gonna stay hydrated
actually in uh the comics batman has
admitted to peeing in the suit
there's uh certain comics where he's
done that and batman and robin george
clooney said that he had to pee in the
suit because in the movies they have
pretty much all the actors and all these
superhero movies they all admit
it's it sucks to wear these suits all
day when they're shooting because they
have to pee
and like with michelle pfeiffer in
batman returns they had to sew her
into the suit i think yeah
yeah yeah they had to come with all
these things i'm not surprised that
george clooney pissed all over the
character
i see the comment sections on all you
guys
and joel schumacher peeing all over the
franchise
had to do it one last time before all
this goes away for good all right let's
move over to the man of steel superman
his
suit is a kryptonian skin suit according
you know to the superman myth it was the
the cloth that he was wrapped in when he
arrived on earth
which makes it sound like not a great
costume for battle by the way a baby
swaddle thing or whatever yeah but he
also like again doesn't need it because
he's superman it doesn't matter what his
suit is
it's all just for the symbolism of his
character he he wears
you know red and blue colors because
he's supposed to symbolize truth justice
the american way
it's not designed for practicality it
was designed to like sell comic books
in the 30s and 40s so he has some of the
problems practical problems he never
really has pockets or utility belt he
has nowhere to carry things and he has
that problem that we're talking about
with peter parker
if he's trying to hide that he's wearing
this if he's always wearing it
underneath his clothes
he has to like go somewhere undo his
clothes and and then
leave them in the phone both right but
at least he has super speed oh does he
leave his clothes in the phone booth
yeah i always imagine he put he presses
them real small
yeah they say open your mouth superman i
want to see your clothes
say ah it's just a pair of glasses in
there yeah what the hell
just people keep thinking that the
person got naked in this in this phone
booth he is fast enough to where he
could like fold them
and tuck them somewhere where no one
would stop at home really quick
you never want to tuck things outside in
just some corner because you know you
don't know who's been there
as our friend ryan discovered he was
like inside he was afraid to get gerbs
and then he
noticed that a homeless person was
peeing on the crosswalk button
and you never know that they didn't
believe that every crosswalk button had
been peed
it was the greatest form of um
pedestrian terrorism
doesn't like zod and the others don't
they wear actual armor as
because they're yes they do and in the
the dceu
david esquire has said that superman's
suit is really kryptonian undergarment
that they they all wear similar type
suits like that when they're walking
around but when they're going into armor
they wear armor over it but it's because
he's you know he's a refugee to earth
and he's more power than everyone else's
relatively speaking uh he doesn't need
that armor
but yeah uh it was designed to just be
like house clothes just something you
wear as you're walking around your
krypton house that used to be a thing i
think like undergarments and stuff
especially men
and like dan lee from streetcar name
desire whatever like kind of like look
whatever or
our dads probably like men just used to
wear
so many layers like they couldn't ever
just expose their skin uh especially if
they're more men
i believe
or you know it's really the equivalent
of like uh sweatsuits
like he just designs it looks lumpy and
goofy but imagine
like if we went to another solar system
and we were super powered
it'd be just like our sweatsuits and our
boxers that we're fighting in
it's like our quarantine outfits
basically where it's like do i really
need to
actually put on like real armor just to
go to the bathroom
no and then i i don't have to ask about
the pain for for superman
because i know that he uses this
freezing breath to make it
ice and then he can throw it right
that's what happens it's established i i
we spent some time
looking into this we don't even know if
superman excretes waste like
just to fit in with the rest of humanity
probably he would go to the bathroom but
like there's like texts in there
whatever and it just like gets up and
unlikely his metabolism works completely
differently well it's like vision we
talked about this with vision didn't we
vision might want to do it to like learn
or something i haven't actually ever
eaten anything before all right let's
move on to wonder woman so
there's a lot you can talk about with
her outfit right she's wearing amazonian
battle armor she's got boots bracelets
the tiara
boots what did i say no i think that's
oh oh i
see i see so yeah there's some problems
with this
and that her body is very exposed you
know she's all arms and legs
but she's also an amazonian goddess she
doesn't really need armor covering every
inch of her
also it looks like wonder woman 84 is
bringing in that new golden eagle armor
that fixes all that
no but that thing looks like it's all
pinch points yep
so really i would see the drawbacks with
this kind of outfit
is like you know as we saw in a league
of their own it's hard to slide
in a skirt and she does a lot of sliding
we see her sliding when she's fighting
those german soldiers and the first
wonder woman
in the trailer for one woman 84 she does
some sliding she does injustice league
she's like
everywhere you think you'd get some
friction burns but her thigh meat is
like impenetrable like so
it's the same thing you're saying about
superman where you know he technically
doesn't need to
need to wear anything she's just living
it up she's miami style yeah
but it's also like does that mean like
the horses don't hurt them either when
they're riding those horses with bare
thighs because if you do any i've never
ridden a horse before
but uh i imagine there's a reason you
wear jeans and you have padding down
there because
it'll chafe up pretty much i'm pretty
sure that the horses are not like
amazonian
powered as well but then that would mean
that
as like with each ride like these
powerful women with their powerful
thighs are like grinding down the horse
sides
like those horses just split in two
after like three rides
guaranteed poor things like you're
trying to sell us
weak horses no horses will split into up
to three rides guaranteed or your money
back disposable horses come and get them
it's where they get the idea of the
horse suit so the horse was split into
and then a guy got in the face that's
right
well doesn't she also wear high heels
she does there's sometimes some of her
outfits
she wears high heels um which make it
really hard to run but that's not part
of her traditional uh
outfit at least when she's going into
battle in the dc eu but the benefit is
she can pee in it she can pop a squat
yeah she wins for pee ability
yeah papa squad is the uh the disgusting
brother of papa smurf who
is in jail
that is me papa squad even gargamel
fears papa's
that guy's not okay so let's talk about
the flash
now really his suit just has to be based
out of a material that won't like burn
up and
fall apart when he goes at super speed
so most versions are
made out of some silica based quartz and
fabric batman says in some comics it's a
material that nasa uses to protect the
spacecraft during reentry
it's like high friction durable stuff
but it sucks because
because it has to be so flexible there's
a little protection if you do get shot
but the guy can outrun bullets so it's
not like he's too worried about gunfire
or punches or anything like that unless
he's de-powered but
in that case he's got other problem
stories but he honestly he gets his ass
kicked all the time whenever he stops
because he's not really protected that's
why you join a justice league so you
have other people who can have your back
for those situations yeah
kids if you're like being bullied and
you feel like what am i supposed to do
about it you find
other kids and you form some sort of
league or
uh like you know this you the
gang and you league of extraordinary
gentlemen
yeah my brother was in a gang for this
exact reason actually is that how he
uh had that kidney stone exactly it was
his initiation everybody
was a kidney stone in kidney stone out
gang
but to answer the question of his uh
urination ability
it doesn't really matter he's got super
speed he could just take off his
suit real quick do his business he
actually probably does take his
clothes home why not it takes him like
half a second to get home it's a lot
easier than stuffing in your gums
superman all right let's shift back to
the marvel universe uh and talk about
daredevil now he's not in the mcu yet
but let's talk about the netflix charlie
cox version
because that's the one we want to be in
the mcu we love that guy so daredevil
has
padded body armor sometimes it's leather
usually it's known to be leather
in the daredevil season one season two
he has melvin potter
build his armor for him and the red
areas protect from knives and
blades and things like that the black
areas are stronger they're usually
bulletproof but because
you know anything leather is super hot
it's not comfortable to be wearing that
all day and to be fighting in it yeah
it's kind of crazy to be wearing leather
for all this
also there was a an issue in season two
like melvin potter was working on was
like a work in progress so any time he
gave him a piece of it he's like
this is what i got for you right now and
then matt murdock would be like well i
need this
he's like all right we'll take it but
it's got some gaps in it
so also uh in daredevil season three
because
daredevil is a masked vigilante and no
one knows who he is
people can impersonate and steal your
identity as we see in season three
bitumen point dexter
impersonates daredevil and gets them
into a lot of trouble so that's another
huge
drawback that we haven't really brought
up because most of these people are
either like
not street level or they're they're so
unique
that like you know no one can
impersonate spider-man unless they also
have spider abilities
can he swing from a web no we can't
he's a pig but also like i don't know
this one doesn't sound that bad like
props for rocking your leather kink so
publicly you know
yeah we never really think about that
with him but yeah sure he likes the
sweaty part
so he probably could pee in this because
the the netflix version of it like
it's not like a crazy onesie like he
could take off parts of it
and do his business uh and it's based on
normal clothes so
yeah he can he can do his business it
does have the drawback though if you get
any like pee in it for some reason for
any reason
that's your kink leather pants are so
hard to put on when they're wet
so just saying if they get wet and he
has to like put him back on very hard
have you tried to put on leather
pants in the rain or something no i
found these wet leather pants
they were already wet no no reason no
explanation
i was dying of thirst so let's talk
about another suit that we've kind of
avoided but it is its own separate tech
with its own separate like history
behind it is the ant-man
and wasp tech they had the hank pym and
scott lang stuff this was designed based
on a motorcycle style suit
that was uh it had parts of it that were
all designed to disperse the the pin
particles
throughout it to shrink all the contents
within it i think this sucks philip
because this resizing tech of the mcu is
super inconsistent and poorly designed
the triggers
are on the thumbs and the moment he puts
it on he's like what is this and just
puts his hands together
and shrinks so as you're fighting you
have to make sure
not to touch the thing that is half an
inch away from where your thumb is at
resting state
it's stupid yeah he probably is getting
like you know a tendon
like problem over time of trying to keep
his his thumbs up
all day long yeah yeah it's stupid and
yeah a huge plot hole about the
inconsistent sizing thing that's like
the biggest plot hole in the marvel
one thing that drives me crazy in the
first ant-man movie he takes the
the resizing pym disc when he's in the
quantum realm he just kind of
loosely shoves it in his belt buckle and
it's like starting to float out he's
like no it's good and closes it
and then you know re-triggers it and
then he resizes and everything's fine
he really just like magruber duct taped
something together
and then all the science aligned
perfectly
what the hell yeah also one thing i
would point out it's got this bulky
stupid helmet that does not have good
peripheral vision
and the goggles are red so like he
throws what he thinks
is a water truck but it's a fuel truck
he can't tell the difference
between what's in this truck and then an
end game all the quantum entanglement
causes them to change ages inside the
suit there's a little baby
who philip pees in the suit oh perfect
so it's got some pluses you could but
it's not designed to be peed in it
you know you really got me on the the
eye goggles if i'm i'm picturing the
helmet really quick
it really is like it's not like they're
like up against his eyes
and like daredevils you know even though
daredevil is blind but like right up
there
it's like this removed thing but then
it's not like a visor
it's still just these little holes so
all they did was cut into his
peripherals
that's it it makes no sense but assume
it is like a motorcycle suit so it looks
like they got a zipper down there but
like at that point why does it matter
you're wearing the stupidest suit
but one last one we have to mention even
though this isn't a suit but it is you
know wardrobe with with some
implications
hulk's stretchy purple pants okay so
he does upgrade his his wardrobe
throughout the films in the first hulk
movie he just wears whatever pants
banner was wearing an age of ultron his
stretchy pants are
right there in the lab on standby ready
to change into them if anything bad
starts to happen in uh ragnarok he wears
gladiator armor
and in game smart hulk has like a
stretchy spandex suit
that he could wear at any time yeah he's
just going to the big and tall store
they're really just there for decency's
sake in real life if someone had this
ability he would not care
he wouldn't care he'd be a nudist if you
become this like giant green monster
you're not like oh no my dong my giant
green dog
but what is good is if you have to pee
or poop you just wiggle those things
down and
we found this great picture that we're
going to show you yep that's that's all
you got to do
and you're ready to go so to answer the
question philip who has the worst suit
there are lots of dumb character designs
throughout all of comics
that we didn't mention we're just
talking about the big major players who
like the movies have said isn't this
cool
like doesn't this look awesome using
that judgment ant-man
i think has the stupidest worst
crappiest suit
in the in the films
awesome it's the least functional the
tech is stupid
it's inconsistent how the tech works the
suit design just doesn't seem practical
it looks uncomfortable by the way
and it's really unflattering and yeah he
pees himself in it so
why does he why does he need it who has
the best suit well in my opinion
i think like the best of marvel seems to
be black panther's suit seems like the
sleekest yeah it's pretty good uh pretty
flexible
uh it can do pretty much everything tony
stark suit can do at least in the mcu
that's how they're making a look in the
dc side of things
batman has an awesome suit that guy can
think of anything to put in there but
really in terms of like overall design
i think wonder woman's got everything
she needs there she's super powered so
she doesn't need all the coverage and
it's hot and she can pee so easily
just comfortable really you have to be
so careful because you just reminded me
of power girl
power girl and her like her boob window
have you ever seen the comic where they
have this stupid boob window makes no
sense
never has made any sense ever did you
ever see when they tried to justify it
no no what did they say she oh god she's
of course like in tears like
the real reason i have a boob window
is because i've always looked up to
superman and he has a logo there
because he knows who he he is but i
don't know who i
am what my symbol is so i left it empty
and filled it with titties like it's
like
no that's not why you you cut it off
you directly quoted what they said it's
pretty close it's pretty close
oh i dropped my rocket's mug
uh it was filled with titties i feel
scared
i bent my titty
um it's just so stupid you would have
left it blank you wouldn't have cut it
out yeah
put anything else there instead of
cutting it out yeah tbd
all right well let us know down in the
comments below who you think has the
best and the worst suit
join this fashion roundup
[Music]
why is it a rave okay uh well before we
move on to some bite-sized questions
now that we are spending most of our
time dealing with all kinds of streaming
content that's like everything we're
doing
it's really more important than ever
than to be able to access whatever we
need
well thanks to our friends at expressvpn
for sponsoring this episode
thank you so much it means we get to
make the show yeah it wouldn't exist
without you
yeah also thank you for protecting our
privacy and security online in addition
doing that they also help you unlock
movies and shows that are only available
in other countries shows like doctor who
rick and morty they're not available on
the us netflix but they
are on the uk version of netflix which a
lot of you are asking me like how do i
watch rick and morty right now and i'm
like
well i don't know what to tell you but
now we kind of do with expressvpn that's
all you got to use
you get the app you change your location
to just one of the locations where you
can do that so like the uk for that
and then you just like refresh netflix
or hulu and it thinks you're a brit now
and it gives you an accent it's
hilarious and but then you can access
any streaming service
just as if you're there and expressvpn
hides your ip address and lets you
control where you want sites to think
you're located you can choose from
almost 100 different countries there are
hundreds of vpns out there expressvpn
is ridiculously fast there's never any
buffering or lag and you can stream hd
without any problems the crazy thing
i've always found about it is the fact
that it works on
like everything like on on it sounds
like i think you could only use on your
computer or something but it works on
your phone
your like media consoles your gaming
console whatever your smart tv which is
crazy so
you can watch whatever you want on
whatever your device your personal
device your big screen whatever without
any problem yeah and if you visit our
special link right now
at expressvpn.com big q
you can get an extra three months free
of expressvpn for free
you can support our show and watch what
you want and protect yourself with
expressvpn at
expressvpn.com big q
big cuties right here oh yeah and these
big cuties are going to answer some bite
size questions
philip is going to tackle him you ready
big cutie big cutie number one
ah big cutie you guys have been here oh
yeah
uh let's hear it phillip crackle jackal
asks
that's not his name cracklejack his name
is crack jack discord yeah
no he's not a crack jackal crackle jack
a crack jackal is a little rodent that
steals your crack
all right the question is in star wars
did lightsabers come before
blasters like was there a time in star
wars history when everyone ran around
with lightsabers like swords and human
medieval history
great question actually if you think
about it what came first you know the
the blaster of the egg
uh and the egg being a lightsaber i did
think it was cracklejack but i think
you're right it is crack jackal and now
i'm rethinking
every conversation i've had with this
person but it's a decent
logic that this person's approaching
with right that swords predated guns in
our history by thousands of years
in our world but not in star wars
actually not exactly
um which is kind of a fascinating thing
it's not explicitly
stated exactly when these things came
about specifically blasters are
almost the most vague but we do know
a little bit about the creation of the
first lightsabers the protosabers the
first blade and the earliest like most
crude device that you could even call a
lightsaber
was a bic lighter all i do is flick my
dick
i it was the res it's it's when they
were experimenting with and here's where
you basically get your answer
they were experimenting with a blaster
shot that they were able to freeze
and keep at a fixed length so a
lightsaber the earliest form of a
lightsaber
is a blaster shot obviously there you
can infer that then they already had
blasters
if that's what they were experimenting
with to make lightsabers but
that doesn't mean that there wasn't
medieval times in star wars
it's just times yeah it just me uh just
where dorks go for birthdays
[Music]
i actually really want to go no one's
ever invited me that's one only not mean
about
it and i know you've been number of
times it would be like our version
of of medieval times where the ancient
jedi their
ancestors did use metal blades initially
and then someone did invent guns and
blasters
and then someone did invent lightsabers
so it's just like our history we
you know metal swords then guns then
somebody's just gonna invent lightsabers
elon musk you're doing stupid change it
to this
so no weirdly blasters came first but
you still get your medieval times in
star wars yay
all right next question i eat zebra asks
who would win in a fight not okay it's
not okay
trophy hunter uh who would win the fight
darth sidious or
thanos with the infinity gauntlet hmm
with the gauntlet right okay you would
think that this would be a
straightforward question with like a
shirt and forward answer you got the
infinity gauntlet and we're so used to
it being this the ultimate device first
of all though i'm going to say i'm only
going to compare the
mcu thanos and not comic book thanos
because i feel like it's only fair to
compare the two versions of the
characters that we know the most and
you know so we should just stick to the
movie versions for both but
first i'll establish on in a one-on-one
fight without the gauntlet
thanos would get his ass handed to him
his big thick ass would just would wipe
the floor
this is based on the idea that thanos
has to
physically fight a lot of characters
that we've seen captain america holds
his own against thanos for a bit
tony stark has drawn blood thor killed
him in the most traditional way you kill
humans lopping off their head
so that means that at the end of the day
he's basically kind of just a really
tough mortal basically but he's
susceptible to traditional physical
attack
palpatine doesn't need to engage people
[Music]
physically
his force lightning alone could cause
incredible damage from like pretty far
away he doesn't even need to get close
but also this is probably his bigger
danger he's got this insane level of
telepathic abilities
i have been every voice you have ever
heard
the more recent movies explored that
more he could spend years if he wanted
to just driving thanos mad
he could trick him into killing himself
for some reason he could do just so many
things by getting into his mind
yeah it's his manipulation skills and
levels of deceit you know that's that's
what's scary i said it previously he
played master yoda like a number of
times he did guys
yeah but thanos with the gauntlet
and let's assume all the stones now
we've got a fight
except i don't even know if it's a fight
at that point
you would think but we're forgetting
palpatine has also not just telepath
abilities
incredibly powerful telekinetic
he can lift a fleet of ships with his
mind meanwhile spider-man almost pulled
thanos's gauntlet off
so palpatine yeah he could straight up
just like um thanos fingers are straight
now
and then he just pulls the gauntlet
right off and [ __ ] like
my man could like just be like ah
and he could wear the gauntlet himself
everybody had
forced lightning in one hand tickle
stones in the other like he could just
do anything
thanos has one chance one way to win it
that i can think of
he has to plot to kill palpatine's
idiots
from afar from so far away that he's not
even on his radar
because palpatine would sense a threat
nearby so he has to be doing it from
very far away
and then be wearing the full thing and
then snap his fingers to just kill
palpatine wherever the hell he is
before palpatine even is aware of the
mcu in any way
right thanos from really really far with
the gauntlet can win
but there's actually another issue here
that i realized if thanos is not
caught up on star wars lore uh he might
not properly think this through
and he might be like aha and he turns
palpatine to ash or more traditional he
pops his head off right
but then he would actually end up losing
because palpatine can survive beyond
traditional debt that's right
he can't turn into a force ghost that's
a light side thing but it's establishing
clone wars
and things that sith spirits can inhabit
places
objects even people so he could
if he's like in the process of being
killed or like oh no something's
happening
he could just jump into another body or
another item and continue to exist
so then thanos thinks his job is done
he's on his
planet he's retired he's cooking that
stew and he like he goes to take a poop
on his like super private
middle of the nowhere toilet and then
just like boom
it's not a toilet it's palpatine
puppeteen ghost
just like exactly
like freddy krueger exactly the worst
nightmare freddy krueger there's like
kind of no way to beat that
i don't think he would like think let me
make sure you also can't turn into
you know assist spirit so i think darth
sidious wins
yeah based on how they've overpowered
the guy throughout all the film series
i don't really know he's kind of god
yeah there are characters in star wars
that are more powerful but we can get
those into those another time yeah
another question
all right third question our good friend
carol on discord asks
but i like this between philip and eric
who would be rick
and who would be morty what's what's
funny so
you sent me this question and i
immediately had an answer and then i
immediately flipped the answer
when i thought about it more so i think
what the truth is here is just
originally when we first met 2006
i was very much your corrupter you were
just this like
innocent little lass and
and you like you were like light on your
feet and you were just so like hopeful
about the world
second guessing oh jeez i don't know
yeah exactly
and i would be like nah we're not gonna
get in trouble just come on
let's kill this dude and you i slowly
like got you to like go along with like
the
more and more crazy things and then
there was that college orgy
oh well now that is some [ __ ]
see a previous episode if you need to
but you were always the one that was
like
oh did we not i don't know one we did we
did we did
people sent me a lot of messages about
it oh okay um oh oh a different
okay different orgy
um god you just set up another question
uh but so i was very much your corrupter
and i think the first minority you ever
met
then as we aged i think now our roles
have flipped
because people don't really know this
about you and you it's not that you're
you're like fake or it's not that you're
like you know it's
they don't know who you really are it's
just i have a very specific version of
you that
i interact with and that guy is much
more rick
now who is like like he's seen it all
and he's like way more grizzled and i
feel like now
i'm the optimist that's like i don't
know eric maybe they want to be our
friends
no no no yeah we can't trust them
they're
uh everyone's just out to kill us you
know what's interesting is
like the series of rick and morty the
characters are now
have started to bleed over into each
other where now like rick is a very
morty s
rick and morty is a very rick-ass morty
so it's kind of like they they kind of
go back and forth and sharing the
qualities as we have
yeah no you're the killer now i know
what you've done from a certain point of
view
cool hey it's time for question box
a box of mails with a couple bags and a
couple boxes
did you put a stamp on it no you didn't
the real truth is we can't pay for our
p.o box right now
how sad is that it just poured out
to us we had to send it to ourselves we
asked for questions and we just
pretended that they mailed them in
our p.o box literally has a lock on it
right now that we don't have a key to
and a private security guard it's like
is this your box
dumbbell door no no no it's not you were
to come here we're gonna put you in
slytherin
i'm snape so uh
this question who was this was asked by
an audience member but they did not mail
it we mailed it to ourselves
eric i'm assuming this is to both of us
but they really want to know about you
uh what was your most embarrassing and
appropriate for this episode
wardrobe malfunction oh
okay i've seen your titties
[Laughter]
yeah philip has been both a witness
and a cause of lots of my wardrobe i
gave you that boob window
yeah you did and including like shaving
things into my head that i
i didn't know were there anyway other
question so the one that comes to mind
is our old improv theater ios r.i.p
we used to have um a couple parties you
know we would have our our del close
awards there's like our dundies
and then we would have like an annual
christmas party i can't remember which
one this was i want to say it was the
del awards because it would always end
with like
they emptied out the theater and they
would just have like a dance floor and
then all these people you were like
too kind of nervous to actually like
make a move on he could just dance with
them and maybe that would turn into
something
i was wearing like my express suit that
i got in college
that was very slim fitting but i
got it because i it made me feel like
ryan gosling when i wore it
it's like this nice silver well-cut suit
but i had gained some weight
but i'm like it still fits it still fits
so like
i'm on the stage dancing flow right as
apple bottom jeans
comes on and then so i'm dancing with uh
these two fly honeys
uh who i can't get away with saying that
well people stop believing the story is
real immediately
uh no just like just these two women who
i was like on various different teams
with and we're just dancing we're having
a good time
and it's the part where it's like shorty
went lolololo
and you dance uh and then you go down no
eric
they're supposed to go down not you the
fly went down
we all did we all went down together
it's not show
it's a little bit softer now well
my ego went a little bit softer then
because
my pants ripped open when i hit the
floor
they went from uh nut sack to butt crack
nut sack to butt sack just it's a butt
sack
a big rip and i immediately
left the whole party i went home and i
waddled my way back to my car and went
home
the next day a friend of mine texted me
a video
and he's like hey looks like you're
having fun last night you could pinpoint
the second philip
where i realized that my pants ripped in
half
and like my face like i was like smiling
and i go
to the video and i just kind of like uh
you know
penguin uh waddle off the stage and i
said
buddy you you can't send that to anyone
he's like why
and i'm like wait i shouldn't have told
him i thought he knew and then he
watched it
30 seconds later he ripped your pants
and i thought he was going to send it
out to everyone but the next day his dog
went missing
oh god so he got forgot to send it
and i felt so bad i think he ended up
finding his dog but my heart broke i'm
like did i will his dog to go missing
or didn't you take his dog that's what
it sounds like it sounds like he stole
his dog
i didn't steal so i wouldn't know you're
the rick you're the rick now
he's the sweetest dog in the world but
he did find the dog
we were really worried that he wouldn't
find the dog but he did find the dog but
he had forgotten about the video and
that's all that matters
was it no it was um
oh yeah how many dogs have you made go
missing at this point
countless i like the image of the pants
splitting and then you like standing up
suddenly like unsure what to do
and i just like my heart breaks for you
because had it been a different time
a teacher would have walked over and put
like a sweater around your waist and be
like
come with me honey
what's it called malarkey
[Laughter]
a woman's first period is knuckle
malarkey you know
nonsense that's what biden's referring
to
period it's all monarchy
uh kids look it up what's so funny is
some reason when you said uh
uh wardrobe malfunction this person
asked that my like brain forgot the
possibility of like
malfunctions i was thinking of like
stupid choices you've made of things you
wore
that's also a malfunction that's a brand
new brain yeah for sure
definitely what came to mind for me i
know you you've thought i've worn stupid
things before but i'm very proud of that
toon squad jersey
it was in college and this was before
you joined our comedy group in our con
what people don't necessarily know about
tsf our old comedy group
is it was it had the stupidest stat
you've ever heard associated with the
comedy group
the like world's largest improv comedy
group which is like no one cares about
the largest one
but it was the largest one so it was
this huge thing so it's really hard to
like climb the ranks and get noticed
and it was my first semester in there
and i was trying to get noticed
and then uh one of the like the popular
guys uh who was like the head of the
whole thing
kind of was like hey uh i wanna i wanna
talk to you about something i was like
yeah
anything jameson and he's like uh uh
i've got this opportunity we're going to
do a haunted house for kids
we just want some of our best performers
kind of just going and he's obviously
trying to talk me into volunteering
doing volunteer work right but i'm like
absolutely he thinks i'm a great
performer i can't wait and he's like yes
if you can figure out some sort of
costume or whatever and then and then
just show up at this uh
well it's a halloween thing it was a it
was a halloween
like a haunted house oh like a maze like
a haunted maze yeah exactly okay all
right and so he's like so just show up
there uh
it'll be set up and then i'll meet you
inside or whatever and so i
i've always been poor but never more
poor than when i was in college
uh i was literally homeless a short time
after this uh
but that's another story yeah yeah
but uh so i want to do the thing but i
don't have anything even close to
resembling a costume i wear the same
clothes every day already
in this scenario so i just like like
find some
some stuff in the house and some some
makeup and stuff
and i just like make this thing happen
and i just put it together
and then in gainesville you remember
that you're poor the only way to get
anywhere is the bus is because you can
ride for free because your student id
and so i walk to the bus stop and
everyone is staring at me the whole way
and this is still close to halloween
like the halloween's the next day so it
shouldn't be so weird
but everyone keeps like making all these
weird eyes at me and then the bus driver
comes and the door opens
and she's like immediately disgusted by
me and i'm like
i really didn't think i went that far
and so i
go inside and she just has eyes on me
the whole time
just like judgment and i'm like feeling
really bad about this about this thing
i'm just wearing you know
uh like like some black pants that i had
and this black shirt that i had i
i'm like this is weird that it's it's so
bad but i arrive
and i go find jameson and i'm like hey
uh i'm here to be
uh spooky scary or whatever uh and he's
like
oh uh um are you sure this is the look
you want to go with uh
and and i do not process what is wrong
with this look so you have to explain to
me
why see i thought it'd be fun to hide in
the shadows and like jump out at people
so i'm wearing black pants and a black
shirt but i literally just used black
makeup and just covered my face
completely in black makeup and i just
have a black face
and i've just been walking around uf
campus and blackface
just in gainesville florida where where
people
might be wearing that for other reasons
uh so i completely like put that
together
do you think people will put that and
he's like yes and that is only what you
look like is that you just
show there is one context for this
that's not because it's not a known
scary thing
of just like oh no the guy with the
black face
it's scary for a different reason so i
like had to wash it off and just kind of
be the like
the screamy guy with like a gray muddy
face
which is also still kind of blackface
like matter
how dark the shade is yeah yeah and like
i like that like i'm a minority so maybe
i would get away with it but by putting
on blackface first of all no i don't get
away with it but second
you can't tell i'm a minority either so
i just could easily be a white guy doing
it oh that bus driver
yeah he had your number yes so she i
i connected like oh i've very much
insulted a lot of people on this walk
that is a wardrobe malfunction yeah at
its core brain malfunction yeah
do not look for pictures of it yeah oh
boy
hey you know what in tsf we had all
kinds of wardrobe malfunctions our
friend liz wore two pop collars
what a mistake she was trying to impress
with not one but two
popped collars oh what a good first day
yeah
she writes for uh jackpots now yeah
she's kicking ass good for her
hey that's our show reminder to join our
official discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars that's where we're
gonna see your questions your big
questions
our friend carol who's been on the show
a couple times she's on discord she's
sending us great questions that can be
any other questions was also from
discord today
hell yeah so uh jump on our discord uh
support our channel help keep us alive
during this difficult time
and you can get your questions up close
and personal with us you can get an
audio version of the show by subscribing
to new rockstars big question wherever
you get your podcast
and for this episode thanks to everyone
who submitted your great questions we
love these this week
reminder that you can uh send us your
big questions on twitter using the
hashtag bigquestion or you can mail us
at our po box hopefully we'll be able to
start paying for it soon i'll be able to
go to crack in there and see all your
great questions uh you can follow me
eddie avas follow new rockstars follow
philip
philip molina and subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube to get too
much information on all this to care
about see you next week
sorry if i offended you i learned my
[Music]
lesson
you